[Music]
House Speaker Paul Ryan is leading the
Republican charge to take on that
daunting task a passing tax reform this
evening I spoke with speaker Ryan in his
office about it but first we began with
his reaction to yesterday's horrific
shooting in Texas Thank You mr. speaker
for spending some time with us tonight
graduations on the new game thank you so
much
another really difficult day for the
country yesterday the Texas church
killer it turns out he was separated
from the Air Force for bad conduct
history did a year in the brig in prison
and then the Air Force never put his
name on the instant background check so
he was able to buy four guns what should
happen as a result victim of domestic
abuse domestic abuse child abuse what
one should be done right so that this
never so he was exposed to get a gun in
the first place because we have laws on
the books that prevent people like that
from getting guns so that's that's
what's frustrating about this is the
laws are there on the books but you got
to execute the law you got to follow
through the well you got to apply the
law should there be consequences to the
Air Force well yes so that's what that's
what the Air Force is doing a quick
scramble and what the heck just happened
what went wrong another dad someone
didn't put them in the right side now
law is on the books to prevent a person
like this from getting a gun and that
didn't happen and we've got to get to
the bottom of why that did not happen
and yes there are a lot of questions the
Air Force has to answer on that should
anyone who ever is separated from the
military with a dishonorable or bad
conduct discharge regardless of whether
they do time or not should they be able
to buy a firearm well there are
dishonorable discharges and there are
just other kinds of discharge so I think
you got a bad here doctor you've got to
be careful what that means and so but
this this was domestic abuse so we have
laws in the books that people convicted
of domestic abuse can't buy a gun this
happened this was this was this is
pretty clear-cut
well the result of all of this is of
course in social media people are always
going crazy people are saying horrible
things frankly you sent out a tweet
calling for the prayers which many of us
did the reaction in the celebrity world
to your call for prayers from Michael
keep McCann
Wil Wheaton others basically saying
essentially this is the Republicans
fault and they were praying and maybe
it's time to do something other than
pray speaker Ryan blaming the GOP it's
disappointing it's sad and this is what
you'll get from the far secular left
people who people who do not have faith
don't understand faith I guess I'd have
to say and it is the right thing to do
is to pray in moments like this because
you know what prayer works and I know
you believe that and I believe that and
when you hear the secular left doing
this thing no wonder you've got so much
polarization and disunity in this
country when people think like that it
turns out the man who was the hero in
this yeah it was an NRA member and knew
how to use a weapon and probably saved
the lives of many others the criticism
from Schumer Pelosi etc is Republicans
are bought and paid for by the NRA and
that's why we'll never ban bump stocks
or ARS assault-type weapons you say well
look the bump stop gives you the
Judiciary Committee is working with the
ATF on that alone that issue but do we
believe in the Constitution the Second
Amendment rights of course we do so if
you're trying to exploit a tragedy to
try and infringe on a law-abiding
citizens second Amendment rights no we
don't want to do that but if there's a
problem where a person who should not
have gotten a gun because their domestic
abuser that's something that you've got
to make sure that the authorities do
their jobs we have laws in the books for
a reason we need to enforce those laws
we just passed comprehensive mental
illness reform which we think helps get
the root cause but if you want to use a
tragedy to try and take away a
law-abiding citizens Second Amendment
rights that's a totally different
question altogether let's talk about the
tax bill it's interesting that both on
the left and the right you guys have
some sustained some pretty big
criticisms The Wall Street Journal at
one point I think it was on the weekend
edition said that this bubble bracket
results in tax brackets that are upwards
of almost 50% in that this will
ultimately pave the way for even higher
brackets why didn't why didn't we let
you know what is this Hillary Clinton in
office we're
for higher brackets everyone enjoys a
tax cut all across the board what this
quote-unquote bubble rate does is just
says the millionaires don't get the tax
cut that is aimed for low and middle
class people the people in the 12%
bracket so all it is is it's saying we
want to preserve middle-class tax cuts
for the middle class but a person in the
top bracket 2002 1.6 one family
one-to-one 1.1 to 1.2 or a couple filing
together but they still get lower taxes
so that's the point so look we don't
like high tax rates either but what
we're trying to do is make all of this
work getting Texas down on on businesses
for jobs for leveling the playing field
but the goal of the tax cut is to aim it
toward the middle class and that's what
that's that's also the upper income is
not getting a tax cut that's really I
mean if you're unless you have like a
pass they're not getting a protection
rate sorry because here the president
was really clear with us about these I
don't want to top I don't want the top
millionaires getting a bigger rate cut I
want that to go to the middle class into
the class warfare mentality in your
better way plan you had a border
adjustment tax that would have raised a
lot of revenue and allowed for true
simplification and true reform and the
who was the person who stopped the
border adjustment tax which was
criticized as a v80 tax but which most
countries have who star I'd say it was
the retailers the retail industry I mean
just couldn't get consensus on it we
believe that that was the smartest thing
to do on a big fan of that I think it's
a smart thing to do to put American
businesses on a level playing field with
the rest of the world and what I've got
now some trillion dollars that cut taxes
across the board but that's behind us we
now have consensus this is the the tax
cut is an average of eleven hundred and
eighty two dollars for the for the
average household in America that's who
this is aimed toward it's it's about
giving break to the middle class and the
people who are living paycheck to
paycheck and then labeling the playing
field for American businesses so that
they can have higher Jeff look at the
tax foundation just told us this thing's
gonna create almost a million new jobs
it's gonna give us more more growth
higher wages
why did you change it today why did
Brady a jungle that's a pickle that's
that's a manager's amendment you put a
bill out there he got feedback he
applied some of that feedback to the
bill that's out
impartial for the legislative process
it's got a retroactivity though there's
an issue with the retroactivity they're
looking at all sorts of different things
and it's about making the numbers work
and getting the best policy possible and
taking feedback from our colleagues
about how to improve the bill as best we
can do you think rates are too high in
the United States course I do what
should they be for every book I'm an old
flat tax or I I'm an old Jack Kemp Steve
Forbes type tax guy so that I think it's
obscene that people any individual can
spend this much time working this hard
as they do
and then 0.6% in a certain income
bracket to me that's just it's why wait
why Republicans in charge we're still
lowering people's taxes but look at this
we are so dramatically simplifying the
tax system 90% of Americans would get to
use this 19 out of 10 Americans because
of the dramatic overhaul and
simplification getting rid of loopholes
getting rid of carve outs and just
cutting people's tax it agrees that's
the big yeah bill is going to pass that
this is what happened with Obamacare
repeal you actually moved up on we
passed that you know you got it through
and it died in the Senate because you
have two people at least Senator McCain
and Senator flake who I believe do not
want Donald Trump to be a successful
president that's my belief you have one
more person who votes against it maybe
it's Lankford and you got no tax reform
how concerned are you that for all this
work you guys have been doing right you
know some people don't still don't like
it but you did something goes over to
the Senate and dies how worried are you
I should have brought my other chart in
my pocket we've passed more bills here
in the house in the 10 minutes of the
first 10 minutes of the Trump
administration under Obama Clinton in
both bush so what are you gonna say that
to McConnell so what they're in work for
three days a week here's look I'm not
gonna get into their schedule but here's
the deal this bill cannot be
filibustered the way we wrote this bill
that's the bubble rate and things like
that are because we have to follow the
Senate rules so that this thing cannot
be filibustered
and here's what we did differently than
health care we agreed ahead of time what
this would look out we meaning the House
the Senate and the president agreed
ahead of time what this thing would look
like what this tax relief would look
like middle-class tax plan I can well
it's just they're all part of this
discussion yeah
that's why it's really important that we
deliver this for the American people for
the American economy but more
importantly the fact that we agreed
ahead of time what this would look like
gives me the great optimism that we're
gonna get this done
congressional approval is about 22
percent even lower than President Trump
is depending on which poll you look at
about 37%
why is congressional approval this well
because we haven't gotten these things
in law yet yeah so like I said I can
walk you through about two hundred
eighty-five bills we passed in the house
that are that are still kind of going
through the system but people want to
see differences made people want to see
it get done they want to see bills and
president trying to get better that's my
point that's that's the final point I
was gonna say is the reason we push for
these bills now is to improve people's
lives to show that there's a big
difference for having this unified
republican government that's why we see
ourselves as the onion room of
government in Congress we're working
here and getting these things done
pushing them but we got to get them over
the finish line so that people can see a
real difference the bushes over the last
10 days in different ways have attacked
Donald Trump George HW self called him a
blowhard George W said and basically
didn't didn't like him didn't know him
gave a speech failed attacks on Trump do
you think that's helpful for the entire
Bush family to be leveling these attacks
only as for any Republicans to go after
each other I think we should stay
unified I think we have common
principles and common beliefs and
priorities that we all agree on so let's
go focus on that and get things done I
see a president who's a risk-taker who's
willing to lean out there and get things
done he wants things done yesterday I
think that's good it shakes up our
system a little bit around here well why
are the bushes so upset I have no clue I
haven't talked to him theory you've been
around for it but I haven't talked to
you about why they're so upset
Bush republicanism the wave of the
future or is it more of a populist
conservatism that's growing across the
country get things done prove our
principles work improve people's lives
that's the kind of republicanism that
should unify everybody its results
republicanism results conservatism
that's what I care about and that's what
we're focused on doing how's your
personal relationship for the president
very good
Larry we talk all the time I mean he's
an Asian house we're not talking you but
we talk quite often can I pick up the
phone and call him and then anytime
anytime you ever tell him not to tweet
he pulled me out of a tree stand on
Saturday morning last week oh yeah
but uh yeah we talk all the time and we
talk about everything we talk about
policy we talk about families we talk
about our kids we talk about everything
speaker Ryan we really appreciate you
taking some time but thank you all my
graduation joining us